jasper works at the intersection of
machine learning and physical real-world
data
currently
they're working as a scientist for
machine learning in numerical weather
prediction
at the coordinated organization
ecmwf jesper holds a phd and recently
gave their first keynote
they're passionate about teaching python
and elevating people's careers
with machine learning across the world
please welcome jasper
thank you for the intro
um
all right
so
this talk is about how you can guarantee
that no one understands what you did in
your machine learning project so it's a
bit of a cheeky take on
um
what not to do um
and kind of yeah i'll i'll tell you
about the things that i use in my work
as well to uh kind of communicate these
kind of models um i work with
deep neural networks so the very
uninterpretable
um networks
all the time
like
i've done my phd in it i've worked in
the last company in it and i'm working
in this company with this technology so
yeah
i
i really have to learn how to how to
communicate these projects
so
why do we do it well
we have these awesome projects right we
we work on these really cool things and
um we put a lot of brain power into them
and they're they're awesome so
the problem really is that
we get really bogged down in these
details and it's kind of like a mechanic
in a shop you get really excited about
the car that you're working on but no
one understands what you're talking
about
and
you still have to communicate your
results to stakeholders to your
colleagues to everyone else in your
company or in your university you have
to be able to talk at conferences as
well so really communication is super
important
and um that's kind of why
i also got my current job so
i i work in um numerical weather
prediction and i have no background in
numerical weather prediction i am a
geophysicist by background i used to
work with seismic data and
i basically got that job because
um i could show to them that i'm good at
communicating these machine learning
results to people that have no
um real idea what machine learning
actually can do
and i think it's it's a really important
skill and when i when i wrote about it
like i i write online um people were
commenting on it i had like one general
manager from dell uh comment on
on my post essentially saying yeah this
is really important the other one is
operationalizing machine learning this
is not this talk but yeah that's the
motivation i i think it's really
important and i think it can
really set apart our projects put them
in the right light and yeah
get ahead in in our careers
as an outline uh basically i want to
talk about communication first
then
look into ethics because surprise that's
really important and then we'll go into
explainability
and
well in explainability i'll also talk
about interpretability and causality
because in my head they kind of belong
in the same area of topics and
yeah then go into data visualization
because it's really really good for
for making things understood
and then talk about interactivity
finally some model validation
and
then i have some conclusions in the end
of of course
so
we need to be able to understand how
people understand things
to be able to work against it this talk
is about
making everyone not understand what
you're doing
so
how do people understand things they
understand your language so
essentially if you use more jargon
people will understand less
so
um think back when you were trying to
understand machine learning or data
science for that matter when people were
talking about the trained test split you
were wondering if they were talking
about an actual train
or about training data and were just
using it funny and
yeah if you
simply just talk about train data it's
going to be quite confusing like most
people will understand you're in the
machine learning community but actual
people in the real world will have
struggles with this like i'm i'm not
even kidding on this one so be
be aware how you frame something
and then um people really
understand things by relating to things
they already know so in my case with
these people in weather
they are really good in statistics in
many cases so they have worked with
probabilities and probabilistic
predictions a lot and they know a lot
about physical inversion so being able
to relate
my machine learning projects to their
physical inversion is really valuable
because
they immediately go like oh yeah i
understand this because this is like
this so it's really helping
in
in getting your point across when you
can relate to things
people already know and you don't have
to be like super specific um
it helps and of course this this comes
down to empathy and also to preparing
for these kind of meetings like who are
you talking to
and what expertise do they have so where
can you kind of hook in your machine
learning
to be able to explain it to them
then
people need to feel heard in a lot of
these meetings i have with
uh with domain expert with subject
matter experts i'm going to use them
interchangeably um it's really important
to be quiet
so
you
oftentimes you have to leave people room
to digest what you're saying of course
but also leave them room to speak
leave them room to ask questions
so when you can
adequately like
i i really recommend anyways to to
almost no to anyone to
um read about communication how to be an
active listener and yeah mirror the
question back to them and then try to
answer the question in in the best
possible way and if people feel heard
they're much more likely to trust you um
especially they're going to trust your
expertise as well because are able to
like empathize with them
and then um
have their concerns addressed so this
one is essentially
going further into these questions when
people think about machine learning they
have heard about black boxes and
i mean
i i know i'm not the younger generation
anymore i'm still struggling with that
but uh
there are a lot of like older folks that
you're working with these people have
seen ai before
they have heard the claims in the 80s
they have or yeah 80s and 90s and
they've seen the last ai winter they
heard the promises of expert machines
expert systems
they heard about lisp and all these
things
and
also how bad
neural networks performed back in the
day so addressing those concerns and
being very open about yes but
we have made all these changes and we
have these bigger computers better data
sets so really going going and talking
about their concerns
not dismissing them is really important
to
um yeah to have people feel understood
and to have them understand what you're
saying
so obviously we need to work against
that to have them
not understand what your machine
learning project is about so how do we
do this
well we communicate like a proper pro
you ignore subject matter expertise so
for example um
when i worked with people in space
i i did a lot of like modeling with
satellite data and that meant that you
definitely need to
ignore anything they say about like the
bands and hyperspectral imaging and all
the information they have about like the
locality where you're actually doing
your study like dismissed
that is the best way to communicate like
a pro
then
you want to dismiss existing solutions
it's really important like if people
work decades on a solution and have
really refined the process just swoop in
with your machine learning solution and
say yeah this is going to replace
everything with just one model because
it's super easy
of course to uh replace like
decades of work with just one neural
network so
really
being dismissive is is a is an art form
there and you have to be really really
well
self self-aggrandized and very sure to
just say yeah i know it better
then
absolutely no need to build trust you
just want to like get into the meeting
just be like this is my solution this is
the accuracy and just yeah basically
finish up
pack your lunchbox and be out again
then never set expectations um
machine learning is magic essentially
right and everyone intuitively
understands what you're doing so setting
expectations is really
counterproductive to
having them not understand your machine
learning model
so any kind of limitations
any kind of time constraints data
constraints
constraints and computation you really
do not want to talk about because that
might mean that people actually
understand
what you did
and this is especially true and i had
this in multiple
um
situations
you
don't want to set expectations about
labeling
um turns out labeling is one of the most
important things you do in supervised
learning
your data somehow
needs and y to the x so if you do your
machine learning modeling you
need some kind of target variable
and
getting these labels is oftentimes
really time consuming and sometimes even
expensive oftentimes actually expensive
so
talking with stakeholders and product
managers about this
is going to be very counterproductive to
being not understood um
yeah
so these are communication tips that
that you should definitely
follow if you want to be
misheard then
next
i think oh yeah
also there's a bonus for for
condescension if you're being
condescending because
you just finished your machine learning
boot camp you know better than anyone
that has worked in this field
that is that is really really valuable
if you can be condescending about your
work
that's the cherry on top
and yeah next
let's have a look at ethical
considerations
because
um if you go into
any subject matter these people have
been working in there for a long time
and i know uh computer scientists and
i'm a physicist by background so me
neither
haven't really done any social studies
um
some people actually look down on social
studies it's it's a thing
unfortunately and that means we don't
really understand ethics that well
uh we kind of know it exists and it's
old philosophers that kind of thought
about things and today also social
justice warriors that kind of do these
things
but if you go into
a field like medicine that's why i put a
picture of a doctor
pointing at things which is
convenient
this doctor has worked in this field for
decades probably and
knows about all these ethical concerns
knows what is being done
to
basically
yeah to to work with
with any kind of ethical considerations
so here are some of the
the evergreens that you have um like
privacy concerns this is especially true
in medical
you want properly anonymized data and
you want to be careful that your machine
learning model
doesn't use any protected classes for
example
because this can really get you in hot
water especially in healthcare you may
have heard that deepmind
basically left healthcare because turns
out it's really hard like um
not not just the machine learning
problem that one is kind of solvable
like especially if you go into x-ray
those are kind of solvable in a way
but
working with healthcare and working with
regulations is in in healthcare is
probably one of the hardest things you
can do
so
yeah working around
in the u.s it's hipaa
you have these everywhere um
but this doesn't it's not just medical
so
for example in
satellite data oftentimes you can
combine different data sources so think
about if you have satellite data and you
have energy consumption data
if you are not careful
about um
only using aggregate
data in that energy consumption you can
have some very specific knowledge about
what people do at what times because you
can essentially
have their locality from satellite data
and then combine that with other data
sources to circumvent a lot of privacy
and
a couple i mean we've heard of cambridge
analytica as well and what facebook is
doing what google is doing they know a
lot about us from just metadata and from
inference by grouping us with others so
privacy concerns
definitely dismiss them if they come up
with with
your stakeholders because this will
erode trust like nothing else
um anonymization kind of goes with
privacy concerns a lot of times you
want to be careful that your data is
properly anonymized um this can also be
a form of data leakage or data snooping
there are different words for it in
machine learning so you have to be
really careful about it to
properly
scrub the data of any
personally identifiable information
and then problematic applications
i recently talked about this like face
mask detection um which is
like you you think this is a cool
application
like it's a nice computer vision problem
that you can do in your free time it's a
nice um project however if you think
about it like
um
we have seen that
the people that don't wear masks don't
care like even if there's an actual
person
they're telling them
telling them to wear a mask
and
that means this kind of model is not
useful
for this kind of application that means
this kind of model is only going to be
applied at um things like protests
probably peaceful protests because like
these exist and um
yeah this is only going to enforce power
structures further and
people in the field will be able to tell
you immediately so if you dismiss this
perfect to erode
trust further
then
um discrimination so
we've recently had it
that
so i i recently learned that the boston
housing data set actually has a column
in there which is just titled b
and apparently that stands for
um
minority or yeah
minority
uh housing
so having that in your data set is
problematic
it's not great so
um
yeah
you want to be careful that your model
doesn't take these input variables but
also you want to be careful that it
doesn't discriminate against people
there was this problem that
the new apple card where you could get
approved immediately with machine
learning of course and all that stuff um
was
used on
a couple essentially and
so man and woman and
the man had a very high credit uh
um um how do you call it very high
credit in in this card and the woman
didn't and it was like they had the same
credit scores shared finances everything
was shared but
something in the model
looked a lot like discrimination let's
say that way so
be super careful there
and then of course policing so
if you
work with any kind of social
social place you want to be really
careful
last pi data i had a really really
interesting conversation with someone
that worked in
social courses and
someone approached them to do a data
science project to identify
uh possible
um criminal developments kind of like
minority report it sounded a lot like
minority report but if you talk to these
um institutions that do social work
we know exactly what causes
um
what causes
criminality in these places which is
poverty so if you send more policing in
those areas you're just gonna make it
worse and all these ethical
considerations are really really
important for
what
uh
what you're doing and to make
um
experts trust you and work with you so
yeah if you want to erode trust these
are really good to dismiss
then
be super specific about your models
stakeholders love nothing more than a
detailed readout of your parameters and
model size learning rate schedules and
hours of training like um
between us i think no one cares actually
like it's such a small part of your
machine learning
modeling
you you probably can just ignore it and
talk about things people actually care
about so
i want to talk about tools
and if you want to be extra confusing
take this as a as a signpost that you
want to avoid them if you want to
explain things to people you can
definitely use these but who would right
um so baseline models these are existing
models so for example in
in satellite data i worked a lot with
experts that were running
my model against their model and would
see what happens interpretable models
are really good too so really compare
your fancy new
neural network against something that
already exists because then experts can
actually understand what you're doing
and how well you're actually doing in
relation to
what they have done so one of the
simplest baselines is the dummy
classifier and cycle learn i love it
it's uh basically just a
what would a random or most frequent um
you can you can put different settings
which is really awesome classifier do
and see how it works against it and this
is one of the baseline models but if you
have like a proper baseline models from
the experts use that one um this is like
this is really good like working against
the bed uh baseline is very valuable
then explainability so we use
statistical methods to explain black box
models
um explainability like using shap in
this case we have these
wait a second these feature importances
and we can see how
a high and a low value of a feature
importance
impacts our predictions so in this data
set we're
predicting the player of the year i
think
um i just took that from the from one
example on cargo i have all the sources
listed i'm going to share the the
presentation in in the slack later and
yeah so a high number of gold scored
means that you're more likely to become
player of the year and a very low number
is going to
be detrimental to that um interestingly
red and yellow on the red cards don't
impact it at all so
this way you can really communicate with
experts and they can get an
understanding of how your model thinks
and how your model interprets the
information and that way they can really
see like kind of sense check against
their intuition that they formed over
decades of working with this kind of
data
this is how you build it so we have a
random forest classifier we can fit it
and then we have three lines to get this
nice plot so use shap it's really good
causality this is going beyond
correlation we know this old saying
causality is not correlation so
we have this arrow if i eat cookies i'm
happy and then we can
take the counterfactual which is just a
fancy word of
checking if the opposite is true if i
don't have cookies i'm less happy since
that's true
um
that this might actually be a causal
arrow that cookies cause happiness
so in the case of mnist for example we
have on the very left here
seven and then we're trying to find
what we have to change about the input
data so about this image to get a
different prediction in this case we're
getting a nine and on the bottom you can
see the iterations of how
um
we're
approaching this kind of uh changed uh
prediction
this is a little bit more involved but
you can use the
library alibi for this you can see that
we have a cnn on the top then we get one
sample of our data then we create a
counterfactual with our
cnn and then we use the explain function
and get
how
uh how certain this is
use visualizations so
abstract information easily digestible
and intuitive so for example this one is
from psychic yellow brick which is
fantastic with its one-liners where you
can um get the residuals
for
your models so you can see if there is
some kind of
a trend in in your uh in your errors in
the data using these kind of um
visualizations is really valuable
because it takes people out of just
looking at numbers and it's really good
to to build yeah more trust and
intuitive understanding with experts
this is how you do it it's literally a
one-liner check it out yellow brick is a
really good library for this and it has
a lot of these
then build into interactivity because
this enables stakeholders to explore
data and to come to conclusions
themselves so
this for example is dreamlit where you
can
go around in a map and just play around
with the data really really good to
build more intuitive understanding uh
this is the code i'm just gonna skip
ahead now
and then we have to think about model
validation so experts know how difficult
their data is to work with
for example with time series like on the
left geospatial data spatiotemporal data
so that is correlated in space and time
and then of course online learning and
for time series for example if we do
just a random split we have the problem
that our data is correlated in time so
yeah it's not suitable because we can
just interpolate our data
so what we do is we use future samples
for validation so only look into the
future for these samples red in this
case is our validation data
there's a special
thing in cycle learn for this
and yeah
we really run out of time and
thank you very much thank you very much
and everybody who connected